>> Tucker: IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU TONIGHT JASON THANK YOU.
BACK IN APRIL 2019.
YOUR LATER "THE NEW YORK POST"
REPORTED ON THE CONTENTS OF THAT
LAPTOP AND OF COURSE THE REST OF
THE STORY BIG TECH CENSORED IT
BECAUSE WE WERE ON THE EVE OF
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
CANDIDATE CAMPAIGNING AND
FUNDING IN JOE BIDEN AND SO
DENOUNCED IT INCLUDING THE INTEL
SAID IT WAS RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION.
>> DISINFORMATION THAT HE KNOWS
TO BE FABRICATED AND SUPPLIED BY
A FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
AND DESPITE THE WARNING HE STILL
IS DOING IT.
>> THIS WHOLE ENTIRE THING IS
OBVIOUSLY A RUSSIAN PLOT.
>> SORT OF A CRAZY KILT AT THIS
POINT.
WHICH IS ALSO ALL MARKS OF
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
LACK OF TRYING.
>> FUNCTIONING AS A RUSSIAN
ASSET BY PUSHING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> WE REPORTED THAT U.S.
AUTHORITIES ARE SEEN THAT THOSE
EMAILS THAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
ARE CONNECTED TO AN ONGOING
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION EFFORT.
>> Tucker: THE RUSSIA HYSTERIA
WILL NOT AGE WELL WILL TAKE THIS
IN TEN YEARS AND WONDER WHAT
COUNTRY WAS THAT?
AND IT'S ALREADY STARTING TO
HAPPEN ALREADY THE LAPTOP IS NOT
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION IT'S REAL
AND SO WAS HUNTER BIDEN.
THEY SMEARED THE REPAIR SHOP
OWNER AS A TOOL OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT MAN IS TAKEN ARCH ACTION IS
A FORMER PERSON IN CHARGE SHOP
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT TO
EXPLAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
WITH US WE APPRECIATE IT.
STAY CALLED YOU OF TOOL OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN WOULD YOU DOING
ABOUT IT?
>> WHILE AND TAKEN THEM TO
COURT.
THE COLLUSION THAT TOOK PLACE IN
MID-OCTOBER OF 2,020 IT JUST
ASTONISHED ME WHEN IT HAPPENED I
COULDN'T BELIEVE IT WAS
UNILATERAL DECISION FOR ALL THIS
INFORMATION WITHOUT DECIDING
THAT IS TO BE ANY COLLATERAL
DAMAGE.
WHICH THERE WASN'T.
>> Tucker: THE COUNTRY WAS
HURT, JOE BIDEN ONE IN A UNFAIR
ELECTION FOR YOUR LIFE WAS
OVERTURNED TO ME WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOU?
>> INITIALLY PEOPLE JUST ASSUME
THAT I WAS A HACKER OR A THIEF
MAINLY BECAUSE OF TWITTER
LABELING THE MATERIAL FROM THE
LAPTOP BEING HACKED AND THEN
BANNING THE SUBJECT MATTER
COMPLETELY.
BUT AFTER 51 INTELLIGENCE
PILLARS OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY SAID IT OR CALL ME
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN
AND ADAM SCHIFF TO ONE CNN TO
FOLLOW THAT UP TO EXPRESS HIS
CONCERNS WITH THE REST OF THE
NATION'S MOST REMOTE FROM POINT
ON I WAS LABELED A STOOGE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T HAVE YOUR
STORE ANYMORE?
>> NO, I HAD TO GET OUT OF TOWN
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
I DO CLOSE THE SHOP IN DELAWARE.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU GOTTEN A
CALL OR AN APOLOGY FROM ADAM
SCHIFF?
>> NO, I DON'T EXPECT TO GET ONE
EITHER.
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU SEE THEM
ALL IN BANKRUPTCY.
AN INNOCENT BYSTANDER CHANDER
THE RIGHT THING, A TOOL